dave you and i just got done playing
steel wave which is year five season two
of rainbow six siege they added two new
operators
and a house rework you played a lot of
ace what were your overall thoughts on
ace
um ace is honestly i think one of my
favorite operators that has been added
in in a good while actually um firstly
he gets one of my favorite weapons in
the game previously only fuse
got the um ak-12 love that gun so
actually being able to use it a little
more
throughout the maps it's super exciting
i didn't really i'm not really a shotgun
guy so i didn't touch upon that
but his selma ability to
to hard breach those reinforced walls i
thought
was really interesting being able to
kind of stagger
the the breakdown and it almost you also
use it as
a distraction or we try to use it even
as a bait
a few times it it feels like it has a
lot of utility but also a lot of
risk that comes with it because you're
opening
a huge gap that the defenders
a will hear so fast because the thing is
loud and then that that huge gap that
you've created is just
is a new angle for defenders to peak so
i think after playing with them for a
while
you are going to learn that it's it's
going to be an operator that needs to
work in tandem with a lot of other
things like i don't
all the times that we try to hard breach
using only ace
failed i think you need to use ace as
as one of many entries because it's just
so loud and the gap is so big
um that that you need to minimize the
the risk that's coming with aces reward
if that makes sense
yeah totally and and it it's slow right
like to get that full
giant hole it can take a while so it's
easy for defenders to set up like you're
saying like they can see that
get in position and just wait as that
thing slowly expands
or they can destroy it quickly with
kaid's electric charge or
bandit or they can use a mute jammer
which will stop it it won't destroy it
but it'll stop it in its place so if
that mute jammer gets destroyed or moved
then it will continue its animation and
it will keep rolling down and destroying
the wall yeah if you think you're being
clever and trying to open
um like a side that you think is
undefended as well and there was a game
where
i caught one with impact grenades and i
got the sense that
the people on the other side now that
their summer was broken they just kind
of
didn't know what to do they're like well
they know we're here
there's now a huge hole in the wall that
can be shot out of
but not big enough that we can go
through at that point i was able to pick
off someone off of
house roof and a balcony so
yeah like i said it plays into that risk
reward um there's there's
quite a lot of counters and being able
to get lucky frags out
as well it's um it's gonna be super
interesting how
it synergizes with a lot of other hard
entry
and kind of distraction abilities i
think
yeah totally and he also comes with a
breach charge and smoke grenade uh for
those interested
but then the other new operator we got
was melusi which is a defender of course
and malusi is interesting because she
has three charges she could set up uh
pretty much anywhere she can't throw
them she has to be like on the wall
in order to place them and basically if
a
if an attacker goes near it it will stun
them so they'll
it'll slow their movement speed but it
won't slow their aiming speed so if
they're quick to react
sometimes they can turn around and kill
the defender however it can be pretty
jarring and the only way you can get rid
of it
is by melee and i imagine with
explosives too you might be able to get
rid of it but it
is it can be tough to deal with and it
can be pretty jarring
um but i had i had fun playing as her
because it was fun setting up little
choke points with those things where you
just find a path and set a bunch down
and then just kind of wait as operators
would attackers would try to get through
there and you would just cut in there
hopefully you could take them down
before they made it to you but i i found
her super interesting
yeah she was an operator that i thought
you could be quite reactive with
previously i felt
a lot of operators you put your gadgets
down during the prep phase and then
like they're there but with me lucy i've
i've
i started thinking about a bit more like
are they going to quick push through
this door
quick put down um one of my banshees
and then as soon as they rush this door
they're gonna be slowed and stunned
and right for the picking yeah she she
kind of seems like she could work as a
roamer and uh
and an anchor i was playing her more as
a roamer i think but i think you could
probably get away with both play styles
which is fun i always
tend to prefer defenders that have a
little bit more flexibility but we'll
see how that shapes out
as for weapons though she's got the t5
smg which is the same as legions
she's the only other operator with that
smg which is good because legion is one
of my favorites and i love his
smg and then she's got the super 90
shotgun and then as for gadgets she's
got the deployable shield and impact
grenade
so the other big thing coming to the
season is the casual rework of house
they kept saying casual because they
wanted
people to know that house this new house
is not intended for
ranked or competitive play at least not
necessarily
uh but they changed one of i think
siege's most
iconic maps quite a bit and it's
interesting i need to play more to see
if i really like it but some things that
really stood out was that you can no
longer peek above the garage which
was frustrating because there's that
window you could smash and you could sit
over
and a lot of people would go straight
for the garage because it was easy to
breach
but now that area is kind of gated off
so
if you can still kind of peak but your
angle is really limited you don't have a
view of that
whole area but then the other thing too
about garage is that there's only one
garage door you can breach now the other
one is
metal reinforced you can't get through
it so
it seems like they've definitely tried
to take a lot of focus off that
side of the map which makes sense as
much as i liked attacking that side
it was definitely like i think it was
definitely in the attacker's favor
it's nice now with a few reworks that
people are going
over some more some different sites i
think and go
for different objectives and entry
points because
previously in-house there was it was
very minimal like
that the thing that the avenues you
respect people from
personally i don't know why they keep
referring to it as casual because i felt
like this experience with house
was a lot tighter and a lot
even more more thought out it felt it
felt more like a more tactical house
like i wasn't having to
scramble through bedrooms that i like
it felt more like the recent siege maps
that there was a little more
brought into it and you know siege has
developed so much now it makes sense
that some of its oldest maps are getting
some new thought added to it yeah
totally and i'm
curious to see what people think of it
because like i said house is such an
iconic map
and it was one of my favorite maps but
it's also i would say one of the
simplest maps
and i'm curious to see all the new
tactical
strategies that people will come up with
at this new reworked house the other
thing i do want to point out is
construction
the construction room is finally done uh
which is
a nice touch i think because you know
the game's been
out for five years now and construction
has been under construction
for that entire time uh so it's kind of
neat to see how they kind of took the
lore of the map
uh it evolved it that way but yeah
that's the house rework
uh i'm excited to see what people think
of it once it
goes to once it hits a wider release but
then other than that
uh just some things i want to tie up
there is a new defender gadget the
proximity alarm
uh which you can throw on walls and it
will make
loud noises as defenders attackers walk
near it and attackers can shoot it
unlike melusi's gadget
so if you see it you can just shoot it
down right there and then the other
thing amaroo is getting a buff
which i think is much needed basically
the
there are a couple small changes but i
think one of the big ones is that right
when you grapple onto
a window the window won't break it'll
break just before you're about to get in
the idea is hopefully give her more
give her a greater element of surprise
i'm not sure
if more people will play her now but i
don't know
i couldn't really get into omuru she was
fun but
i just didn't think she was super useful
we'll see if this changes things but
anyway
that was year five season two of rainbow
six siege steel wave i'm very excited to
play more but let us know what you think
in the comments below
thank you so much for watching
[Music]
you